bonjour mademoiselle la fumée ne vous
inquiète pas trop a tout dit monsieur je
m'excuse de famille et moi-même de pour
écrire c'est un commode cher aux ordres
mais si vous n'avez pas de papiers les
agenais pour écrire là n'osait pas
oublier le papier mais principalement ça
on assez d'exemples s'il vous plaît
alors vous y êtes bon mon cher ennemi
alors cénomans terre
ah oui et comment bâtir notre pays mon
chéri tu mens mon cher et demi je suis
arrivé à orléans vers 3h et virgule tout
de suite virgules
je suis allé voir le no 7 oui après ma
première impression n'a pas été très
bonne non et je ne veux pas tardé
d'apprendre que la chose est bien plus
compliquée que nous pensions tous
compliqués que vous ne le pensiez
comment que vous le pensiez que nous ne
le pensions a oui que nos intentions
j'aurais pu téléphoner à sa fête
mais la réflexion j'ai préféré et écrire
afin que tu puisses montrer ma lettre à
berjon acquis à mon associé ben oui mais
c'est son nom qui m'a échappé
ah pardon père je romps par jour je dois
te dire que le dernier testament qu'elle
l'a fait n'est pas écrite de sa main à
la ligne confidentielle
vous pouvez compter sur moi pardon vous
pouvez compter sur moi non c'est pas
jeudi 10 à 7 heures mais alors vous
écrivez confie l'ancien j'écrivais un
confidentiel
la personne en question est peut être
encore là où tu penses mais soit
convaincu que si gaston obligé susanna
rendre à germaine ce que tu sais nous
aurions dans les mains tous les éléments
que tu supposes
qui va comprendre comment si je crois
mais j'en suis sûr je n'arrive pas non
mais c'est possible mais c'est poser
mais lui comprendra amusement pardon
vous en prie métro rade et m'a dit qu'il
se rendrait en personne demain au
château de sa mère apuanes mais ça l est
à 300 kilomètres d'ici trois ans 40 des
personnes bien informées prétendent même
qu'il y a moins 340 km
je n'aurais donc pas la réponse avant 48
heures
je me suis tromper d'ennemi 47 je vais
vous laisser car je t'enverrai la
réponse aussitôt écoeuré faire jusqu'à
mercredi je n'en sais rien encore deux
jours
c'est via long et pourtant cela pourrait
passer si vite
certes il ne me déplairait pas d'aller
jusqu'à embrase que j'ignore il paraît
que le château est une vraie splendeur
oui seulement voilà faire ce petit
voyage quand il serait si doux de le
faire à deux alors que faire sp à
orléans et attendre la réponse de radés
à 6 encore je connaissais quelqu'un ici
quand je dis qu'elle tint mon cher et le
front tu vois ce que je veux dire si
j'étais homme à me contenter de
n'importe quelle créature rencontrée au
hasard mais non mais non je voudrais
vous devrez signer charmante à grands
pas trop grande avec des yeux très beau
puis les jeux feront des taches de
rousseur dumas délicate et puis disent
on veut qu'ils seraient pas rouge mais
existe-t-elle
et si elle existe si la rencontre crois
tu qu'il osera que j'oserais mois le
droit des 24 heures de sa vie
et quoi tu qu'elle voudra consentir à me
faire visiter ce beau château d'amboise
et croit dit que pour l'en remercier je
pourrais lui offrir ce petit monstre de
vison que j'ai pu tout à l'heure dans la
vitrine d'un magasin qui se trouve sur
la place de la cathédrale à gauche en
remontant la rue gambetta le crois tu
mon chevènement excusez moi monsieur
puis je me permettre de passer un coup
de téléphone mais je vous en prie
mauvaise alors le parti s'il vous plaît
à tout le corps qui donnez moi tout de
suite je vous prie le commissaire de
police alors à l'eau à nous c'est toi
papa audi dont figure toi qui est le
patron qui m'envoie pas dans 24 heures
à amboise je peux malheureusement pas
refuser bien sûr
alors sois gentil diamants qu'elle
mettra pas mon petit sac de voyage
non non je crois pas j'ai ce qu'il faut
comme mentaux merci papa
enfin oui mon père est commissaire de
police
le militaire où se fasse beau nous en
étions à ce petit magasin qui la gauche
s'oppose aux cathédrales dans la rue
gambetta c'est ça on s'arrêtait et comme
formule de politesse pour l'embrasser
moi je veux bien moi aussi